urnas electorales a domicilio es para
votar por el referéndum ahora la puerta
Por favor ya les
abroñés los combates son frecuentes y
los habitantes dudan en salir para
evitar el abstencionismo todos los
medios son válidos esta supervisoras van
de apartamento en apartamento buena
medida porque tenemos miedo de salir si
hay tiros en la calle y bombas que caen
porque buscar problemas nos quedamos en
casa esta supervisoras van de
apartamento en apartamento la pregunta
formulada está usted de acuerdo sí O no
con entrar a la federación rusa usted
está a favor Por supuesto que sí todo
cambiará encontraremos el buen camino
Rusia nos ayudará con todo las
autoridades se aseguran de que no haya
fraude
cada urna está marcada está sellada y
cerrada herméticamente
siempre está vacía cuando La cogemos y
luego cuando la llevamos al puesto de
votación comparamos el número de firmas
con el número de boletines depositados
así funcionaría idealmente pero no es el
caso de esta mujer que no está inscrita
máximo
menor pero no está aquí frente a
nuestras cámaras votará por ella
[Música]
prisión verdad no yo soy la supervisora
cómo es posible esto nos dirigimos a
pedir explicaciones a la responsable
encargada del puesto de votación
esta mujer votó por su hija
Yo tampoco entiendo Qué pasó está un
poco molesta
comprenda la supervisora son jóvenes Es
la primera vez que hacen ese trabajo de
pronto tuvieron un problema técnico lo
que podemos hacer es anular el voto
haremos la declaración e inscribiremos a
la madre en la lista Porque de todas
maneras ella vive ahí los refugiados Al
otro lado del frente de batalla en la
parte ucraniana no podrán votar las
votaciones No solo se realizan en el don
Bass también en dos regiones del sur de
Ucrania controladas casi en su totalidad
por los rusos estos referendos no tienen
ninguna posibilidad de ser reconocidos
por la comunidad internacional pero para
Vladimir Putin legitiman su operación
militar especial a la vez que ordena una
movilización parcial mientras que los
rusos retroceden en el terreno debido a
la contraofensivo Ucrania